this week on quad Riga refugee chaos can
Mirko overcome a party rebellion the
Chancellor's liberal response to the
refugee crisis has earned her praise
across the world but there are growing
calls within her own party to stem the
flow of new arrivals a recent play by
her interior minister for a clampdown on
asylum seekers caused further
controversy Thomas D misère challenged
the Chancellor's prevailing policy he
suggested stopping automatic recognition
of Syrian asylum seekers and preventing
family members from coming to Germany
later as the Chancellor's still captain
of her ship when it comes to the refugee
crisis and how much support does she
still enjoy within her own party coming
to you from Berlin quad Riga the
international debate your host Terry
Martin hello and welcome she's become
the go-to leader in Europe brokering
deals on everything from the eurozone
debt crisis to the Ukraine conflict
Forbes magazine says she is now more
powerful than Barack Obama but even
Angela Merkel has her limits could she
have finally met her match in the
current migration crisis that's the
question we're exploring this week on
quadriga we have three distinguished
journalist with us in the studio to
explore this question is my pleasure to
introduce them now beginning with erik
kirschbaum he is American journalist
from New York he works for the Reuters
news agency in Berlin he thinks the
turmoil in Merkel's party the CDU about
its direction on the treatment of
refugees raises questions about possible
intrigues behind the scenes aundrea
Skloot is berlin bureau chief and
germany correspondent for the
london-based weekly The Economist he
says critics are wrong to assume that
Angela Merkel is about to be toppled she
remains the dominant figure in her party
in Europe and in Germany
kareena Edmonds is a correspondent for
the German public broadcaster ard and
online coordinator for taco shell dot de
she says it's unclear whether Michael
will keep her power though the
Chancellor has shown resolved in an
emergency she says she has made many
mistakes on the national and
international well it has been a chaotic
week in German politics we've been
getting mixed messages coming from the
Chancellor and from her cabinet Eric
start with you is this just a case of
communication breakdown inside
Chancellor Merkel's cabinet or is it
something more serious no it's much much
more serious I mean Thomas Demi's year
is an ally of miracle he knows exactly
what he's doing he's a pretty powerful
figure in the cabinet and he and the
finance minister Choi blur are both
staging a small rebellion right now and
letting miracle no no it's it's not okay
what's going on they're listening to
what's going on in Germany a lot of
people in Germany are upset with the the
the loss of control the borders that
that a million people are coming in this
year it's it's it's the the seeds of a
serious rift in the government that
could be a big problem for miracle
Karina Thomas too busy a witch Eric was
just talking about their we're talking
about the interior minister now he
announced further restrictions on
refugees coming into Germany and the
families of refugees that seemed to
catch the rest of the cabinet off guard
is there a strategy behind this or is it
really that the rest of the cabinet
including mackle didn't know what the
interior minister is up to I would
believe that yes that they didn't know
it I think de Mesilla wants to show his
opinion he has been weakened by of a
political change in administration
because the refugee issue is now part of
the Chancellor read as a new refugee
coordinator called Peter Altmaier who is
very close to merkel de Mesilla was
supposed to be a close ally but in this
issue obviously he has a different
opinion since many months so yeah it's a
bit nasty
absolutely not smart and if I was
Michael I was really would be really
angry it seems nasty indeed in one
wonders whether there's some sort of
subterfuge going on within the cabinet
are we going to see a kind of a palace
coup in the making is mutiny in the
ranks of Chancellor Merkel's government
I don't think so I don't think it is
because even the people who are
criticizing her in her own party in the
Bavarian CSU in the CD you realize that
there's really at the moment no
alternative to her by the way that's
kind of ironic to Germans because
alternative liz is a word that she wants
coined in the euro crisis there it's you
know my policy is alternative less it's
an ugly word even in Germany and there
is even a party called the alternative
for Germany that was founded with with
the sarcastic name to respond to that
but I think ironically it is we are now
at the point where there is no personal
alternative to her they're talking about
the Finance Minister Wolfgang schäuble
is stepping in as an interim chancellor
if she were ousted but neither shoib
Lenore jamias air nor anybody else would
be able to do anything much differently
than Merkel and so they would fail
themselves and in fact I think both
Germany and Europe would fail much
faster but they want to send out some
signals de maizière I want to send out
some signals at Syrians can't bring the
whole family's here they can't stay here
for three years I can only stay for one
years dim is ii-era like him or whatever
he's sending that signal not only to the
Syrians who are on the way to Germany
but to the the rank and file of the CDU
out there yes yes still Angela Merkel if
the Chancellor and he has something like
we call it in German listening and
competence guideline competence and
actually these boys shouldn't go that
forward in the public so why are they
doing it I'll tell you why he's doing it
right now in my view at the moment she's
a weak leader it's no good sign after
our leadership my senior here for my job
in she should keep them cool we would do
the same thing because for him it's in
part at this point self-defense I mean
he's been dumped on for
defense minister and I was interior
minister he has a very tough job yes
next to grind some what are you a few
weeks ago he was dis in fact demoted
when Chancellor Merkel made her chief of
staff pitta at Maya the coordinator for
the refugee policy inside the
chancellor's office and that everyone
saw that as a demotion he's been under
enormous pressure he has to send signals
to the Syrians and to his party hey I'm
still here I still I have competence
over something he also has to worry
about his one oh my god i don't think
that amounts to a threat to her well
it's we wonder because I mean just again
so our viewers understand what what
happened here apparently the regulation
Dublin to agreement or dublin to system
for determining what happens refugees
saying that something that European
leaders agreed on a long time ago
Chancellor Michael suspended it now
demacia apparently reinstated this
policy in October without telling the
rest of the government that seems like a
breach of trust too many if not just
total chaos and breakdown within the
cabinet I want to put it to you kareena
the Chancellor has now expressed her
quote complete confidence in de Mesilla
as as interior minister she's used that
phrase in the past and it turned out to
be the kiss of death is this the kiss of
death for dignus yeah it might be and I
think in another situation where it
wouldn't have been such an emergency
situation like now he might have gone
already because he didn't do a good job
hehe want the whole administration too
late and his institution the Bundys I'm
from the cartoon the institution who is
responsible for migration and takes all
the ideas olam seekers papers and other
day day they were informed too late and
so he didn't do a good job I mean maybe
that's why he now wanted want to show
that he's still in power okay well we
want to bring this discussion back to
Chancellor Merkel herself we'll find out
what happens with de Mesilla in the
weeks
to come then I think there's a lot of
drama left in that mechel has won a lot
of praise for her position on the
refugee crisis extending her viv Commons
cultura as it's become known to the
refugees coming to Europe but she has a
lot of critics to and the barbs that are
being hurled at her now even from within
her own ranks are numerous and sharp I'm
Lestat other countries likewise only
provided guaranteed refuge for a limited
time and that's what we will be doing in
future with the Syrians as well
Madonsela and often via link via we want
to see a restriction on or reduction of
the refugee numbers of course we had to
put a limit on family's arriving later
our intake capacities are not unlimited
it is therefore necessary to check each
individual case and for people in Syria
to be aware that not everyone can come
here that's good nyali it's left out
senko and design is with only if we say
families can follow without any problems
it's dishonest we also have to ensure
that accommodation can be provided which
is where reality comes in it was
materiality so tuned yes reality a big
slap in the face when it comes to the
refugee crisis Karina has the Chancellor
lost touch with reality by saying that
come to Germany all refugees we are not
going to put any upper limits on no she
hasn't lost touch she's just referred to
our Constitution the law of the right of
asylum and and we also signed the Geneva
Convention on refugees so there is she
she's right and she's long-term thinking
and she knows that we have to take our
responsibility but of course we as
Europe not only as Germany behind all
this there's a big failure of European
leaders and just Saul so her failure she
says she's considered to be a strong
European leader why didn't she prepare
herself with oland and Cameron on this
situation it didn't come overnight we
had enough warnings since lumpy Doozer
in 2011 many deaths in the middle and
she is sweety she was perceived as going
out on a limb with this and also going
out with an idea and embracing the
refugees coming to Europe without really
conferring completely with some of our
European colleagues many have said is
andreas pointed out that this was
alternative lists you know edness what
she said to that it can't be but I'm
just wondering about Chancellor Merkel
what has happened heard during this
crisis she has morphed during this
crisis from protective matriarch to
political pray as we're seeing this week
for the first time people beginning to
question her Authority openly andreas is
the Chancellor's power base beginning to
slip she's first of all she's more often
metamorphosed in a number of ways one
from let's say perceived as hegemon over
Europe for instance over Greece as
recently as the summer to now the
position of supplicant going to the
other European partners and wanting
something and maybe not getting that's a
perception thing and that is a striking
difference the other metamorphosis I
would say is she went from a leader who
at least in Germany was always
considered to be leading from behind as
it was or the politics of small steps or
muddling through we would say in English
ed to in this case are almost
spontaneously forging ahead in one
weekend of September fourth and fifth
and and doing something that well
spontaneous and that some people would
regard her emotional and therefore
leading so a lot of people who have been
criticizing her from leading from the
back have turned around since and saying
well now it's not okay to be leading
from the front and I I actually it is
her power base slipping it we will see
it doesn't seem to me i want to quote to
you i'll just sent in her ranks and the
CDU rank isn't out about specifically to
that by the way it her the attacks on
her in parliament will not be coming
from the left which
agrees with her policies and this SPD is
torn internally internally and will not
be out stinger Social Democratic you
it's only her own ranks if you disregard
the alternative for Germany which is
outside of Parliament but in her own
ranks there was a poll by Forza just a
few weeks ago that on the question for
instance should Merkel become Chancellor
again eighty percent of the CDU members
said yes forty percent of SPD members
said that their boss Sigmar Gabriel
should become Chancellor so that's
difference and I don't believe that the
CDU is ready to sacrifice her because
they know a that they would lose
elections without her and be that there
would be nothing else they still think
they might lose elections but if it
keeps going like it is and the CDU is
losing support in the polls the AFD is
back alive again with seven or eight
percent if it keeps going like this and
you hear politicians who have elections
coming up like look nur there's
something to sound very very nervous
because a lot of CDU voters don't like
what's going on and they're unhappy
about it so this is a certainly a
problem for the CDU mainly that America
was a bit too open and now people like
Chauvelin de Mesilla are kicking her
shins and and they're getting away with
it that's the really remarkable thing
they're getting away with it in the past
men who would do something like this to
miracle they'd be history within a few
weeks but they're getting away with it
which shows she's weak I think she's
weaker than she's been in a long long
time so some of her closest closest
allies in in the in the party and if
then the cabinet that got a cabinet
level are now beginning to kind of come
in a contradict her in public we're also
seeing this again what it seems to be a
breach of at least administrative trust
when your interior minister doesn't tell
you that he has changed the rules
reversing your policy memos don't like
chaos in the government they want their
parties to be together and organized it
shows it is a good idea that's true I
mean the question is being raised in the
mind of German voters about the conf it
about the competence of the leadership
in this crisis I mean chancel medical
one a lot of praise as I was pointing at
the beginning but right now we're seeing
a lot of people standing up in public
and saying enough is enough we we don't
even know how many refugees are in the
country this just made the headlines
that the
has admitted they don't really know how
many are there they've had Chancellor
Merkel is having to turn around now on
her policy I'm just wondering eric is
this an is this an avalanche but the
word that the finance minister used last
night in avalanche and he said
avalanches could be caused by people who
are bad skiers sort of making another
jibe at miracle we all know Germans love
control they love an orderly society
they love things that are nice and
orderly and everything is organized and
right now with a million people who have
come in the last two or three months
they feel there's a sense out there that
they're losing control of their country
and that's something that's really
upsetting a lot of people and that's
really hurting miracles party more than
any other okay just before we move to
the our next session how dangerous is
this situation for Chancellor Merkel
Karina how do you reading well it is too
dangerous she knows that and at the end
of the day people will look whether she
has managed the situation and the
question is does she still have the
situation under control both our
government but also the numbers of
refugees and how to integrate them I
think the moment the government is the
bigger problem if they would just stay
together a step back and should say okay
we're going to manage we take some time
but everything is on the way and we want
at one of the richest countries in the
world we can manage the situations all
experts from economies aidan and look
there's local local leaders do a good
job of course they are overwhelmed but
interior ministers in the federal states
are beginning to rebel a bit yes of
course that's part time to implement
these balls clear that's absolutely
clear that it's a maybe most difficult
situation in the last 20 years for of
current politics is a tremendous
challenge and many are saying they want
to know the second one I think from mrs.
Merkel to the people criticizing her
that the only real lever to reduce the
fee
close of refugees it is probably
somewhere near turkey between Turkey
Syria and Egypt right now if you look at
around at Europe who where is a leader
of mrs. Merkel stature if there's
anybody I'm not saying she can do
anything but if there is somebody who
can work with Turkey and the surrounding
countries to to have a solution that
keeps more refugees there then it's
still her there is a big foreign policy
dimension to this and as we mentioned it
at the beginning Chancellor Merkel is
the go-to leader in Europe when it comes
to addressing these questions the does
however bear repeating the question
where exactly does Chancellor Merkel
stand on the refugee crisis you
mentioned andreas that German voters
don't like chaos well the Chancellor's
position on the refugee crisis has been
moving over time on one hand she is very
generous very welcoming towards refugees
but she has been playing a bit of policy
hopscotch lately the Chancellor with
teenage refugee reem on German TV in
July a performance dismissed by many as
cold-hearted but oh and you know
yourself in Palestinian refugee camps in
Lebanon there are thousands of people
and if we say you can all come and you
can all come from Africa and everywhere
well it would be too much for us to
manage that's come in easy shopping
in early September tens of thousands of
refugees left Hungary headed for Germany
the Chancellor's open door policy earned
her the nickname mother miracle Lindy
its unfun it's not actually encima stuff
if we now have to start apologizing for
showing a welcoming face in emergencies
then that isn't my country done if the
snitched my London but that face is no
longer quite so welcoming the German
government now wants to deter new
arrivals and is reinstating the Dublin
regulation for treating Syrian asylum
seekers that means being sent back to
the EU countries they were registered in
so which miracle face is the real one a
lot of consistency there andreia some
can we see do you think we'll see
Germany now backing away from the
commons coutura orchid miracle flipping
I beg to differ that there's this
alleged inconsistency what happened I'm
I watched this event that we just saw
that was this summer the girl's name was
reen she has cerebral palsy she was born
in a refugee camp and mrs. Merkel I
thought when she broke down crying that
little girl showed empathy and then
explained very professionally in sombre
soberly that no Germany cannot accept
anybody which is as it's shangela what
she had to do Twitter then called her
cold-hearted when I thought no that's
that was her job I thought the public
exaggerated that September 4th September
fifths when she allowed the trains from
Hungary to come in everyone we're
shocked in the other direction and said
oh she's a you know bursting open the
borders she wasn't doing that either I
believe she was trying all the whole
time to walk a fine line and that
actually the public this is what it's
like to be Chancellor exaggerates
whatever everything that comes out of
her mouth so I don't see an
inconsistency there what does she stand
now though I mean now she's saying okay
well the interior minister is right we
do need to reinstate the Dublin
arrangement that requires refugees to be
registered in the country where they
first entered the European Union which
effectively means Germany could send
refugees back it's a really pushing an
end isn't doing that because look at
where what does it mean let's just go
terms it's very practical terms where do
these messages easy to enter the
European Union it's in Greece which is
having which is the center piece of the
other crisis we're having end is
floundering and foundering so it's
Germany really now I mean I'm sending
going to send them back to Greece they
can only send back if they have been
registered in these countries but they
are you saying we don't you they don't
even know usually they are just a tier
so it's a kind of what we see there it's
a lot of symbol politics going on
signals signals to the CDU voters and
that's the intention maybe the question
remains which direction this issue when
to go with this year is she going to
pull back and say okay there's been so
much of a backlash now that we have kind
of reached the point where we can almost
say the boat is full I think she's gonna
have to I don't think she anticipated
the rest of the EU would drop the ball
the way it has I don't think she thought
all the refugees were going to land up
in Germany and Sweden so I think she's
being forced by her party to make a
slight retreat here and knowing the way
miracle does these things she makes a
u-turn without you really noticing it
she'll make a bunch of small steps over
a couple of days or a couple of weeks
were there comments and all of a sudden
she'll be saying the exact opposite of
what she said a few months ago she's not
going to close the door on the refugees
but she's probably going to be pushed
along with shy blue and Dame is the air
to do except some of these bitter pills
at least send some signals that Germany
is not going to be able to take a
million refugees and in every year for
the next ten years the problem is as you
just pointed out correctly they're all
signals their signals to the CDU their
signals to the Syrians and to the
refugees in Jordan don't come here but
they're just signals because in numbers
this will not make a difference we don't
know the numbers and the government
today admitted that that they don't even
have numbers anymore but they will not
be sending refugees who are coming here
back to Greece where they were
registered that's earlier unfortunately
are about out of time I wanted to get
your opinion on dreis on the key
question that was asked at the beginning
of the program and that is basically is
the refugee crisis Chancellor Merkel's
Waterloo could this migration problem
lead to the Chancellor's down Paul I'd
like to get a response from all of you
before Waterloo was a great
moment for the British and the pressure
so I you know whose side are you on AB
no I i well I believe unfortunately i
have to say i am very pessimistic for
Europe I think Europe has failed is
failing in front of our eyes to deal
with this and I think these various
crises euro crisis Russia crisis brexit
will come together with the refugee
crisis in Europe will fall apart what do
I think Merkel personally will be ousted
no I still think she will survive okay
Eric I think it's very dangerous for a
miracle I think it could be a really big
problem for her in the next couple of
months if she doesn't get on top of and
get in line with her party um I don't
think she'll be kicked out or forced out
anytime soon but she's been around for
ten years now and I can imagine she
might not make it to the twelfth year I
wouldn't be surprised I don't think it'd
be a total shock for some people if
she's not around two more years let me
push this one step further if Merkel
maybe is not looking endangered at this
moment road what about the other members
of her cabinet could we see a shuffle
reshuffle coming up I would have yet I
would have thought that would have
happened by now or would be happening
but it's not and that just shows that
she's she is a bit weaker than then she
was a week or two ago kareena how do you
see things playing out as we go forward
and we know that the statistics suggest
a chat everybody wants to see Chancellor
Merkel back in power even the opposition
don't really see it an alternative at
this point this is could this mean the
end of her political strength however
it's an open quinn end question
absolutely but it depends on so many
levels of International Affairs foreign
policy how they come along with with
just daily operative questions and 17
shall be two seconds or so keen it's
it's just become more difficult for her
than some months ago to to focus on 2017
and the next Marco Galvin mandates ok
it's more critical now we're gonna have
to leave it there very critical indeed I
want to thank all of you for being with
us this week on quad Riga and do check
us out on the internet at DW calm hope
you'll join us again next week